[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'aurez compris aujourd'hui on va
parler un football nous sommes sur les
terrains d'entraînement du fc versailles
à 78 les hommes de youssef schibbye sont
qualifiés pour les huitièmes de finale
de la coupe de france ils affronteront
toulouse et vise également une montée en
fin de saison
à mes côtés le directeur général du club
jean luc arribart alors jean luc
arribart comment ça se passe depuis
votre arrivée au club c'était en
novembre dernier c'est ça début octobre
début octobre et octobre se passe très
bien puisque l'équipe est en tête du
championnat
en coupe de france on est toujours en
course je peux pas rêver de meilleurs
conditions de meilleures circonstances
pour démarrer on va revenir sur votre
situation personnelle pourquoi que vous
avez voulu venir ici à versailles parce
que les actionnaires me l'ont demandé et
que j'ai accepté je trouve c'est un
projet très excitant nous avons des
ambitions nous avons des moyens grâce à
eux et
genre j'aime j'aime à dire qu on a des
ambitions raisonnables voilà on va faire
grandir le club on va le structurer et
vont essayer d'emmener l'équipe première
plus haut ça veut dire quoi les
ambitions raisonnables c'est vraiment le
faire grandir petit à petit bon déjà on
a l'impression que ça va trop vite non
parce que quand je dis ambitions
raisonnables je pense à tous ceux qui
crient haut et fort qu'ils vont aller
dans l'élite qui vont être dans les 50
meilleures équipes d'europe dans les dix
ans à venir et c'est non on n'a pas
cette cette arrogance là parce qu'on
connaît trop le football enfin en ce qui
me concerne j'ai un petit peu de
bouteille donc j'ai beaucoup d'humilité
c'est pas parce qu'on a beaucoup de
bonnes idées qu'on travaille bien qu'on
a des moyens
qu'on est sûr d'y arriver
on va essayer de bien faire les choses
mais on sait qu'en football c'est allé
il ya beaucoup de parallèles à thouars
donc on
va bosser on va s'organiser bien et on
espère que ça va que ça va fonctionner
mais on sait que ça peut mettre du temps
d'atteindre nos objectifs
on a envie d'aller dans le monde
professionnel donc dans un premier
première étape c'est d'aller vers la
ligue 2 d'avoir un centre de formation
voilà c'est tout ce qui nous anime
aujourd'hui c'est ce projet à moyen et
long terme quel est votre rôle à vous
quels sont les dossiers sur lesquels
vous travaillez au quotidien
allez je vous dire que du boulot à faire
ça je savais qu'un oreilles en acceptant
le poste mais je n'ai pas fac et le
poids c'est prenant d'autant que je
continue à commenter les matches pour
canal donc les matches anglais donc ce
qu'on fait c'est d'abord
organiser une équipe autour de moi parce
que
il veut un vrai besoin de faire venir
des la compétence des gens à fond dans
notre projet et qui vont nous aider à
grandir aussi donc marc mohamed et
mickaël michel sont venus me rejoindre
et puis les structures parce qu'on est
un peu sous structure et par rapport à
notre situation sportive hainaut et nos
ambitions d'autant qu'on est en tête du
championnat si on a la réussite de
monter en national donc il faut qu'on
s'aide combler rapidement plus vite le
retard qu'on a au niveau des structures
donc on travaille sur les structures ont
travaillé en collaboration avec la
mairie qui a une écoute très
bienveillante et constructive avec nous
et donc on essaie d'avancer d'avancer
vite parce que le temps presse et on
voit là il ya beaucoup de sujets et des
sujets à plus long terme aussi oui un
petit souci sur sur le stade notamment
je le rappelle on ne peut pas avoir
d'éclairage la nuit au stade maubon
alors parce qu'on ne peut pas voir une
lumière depuis la chambre du roi soleil
oui enfin c'est est un serpent de mer
enfin c'est quelque chose qui traîne
depuis plusieurs années il faut la
décision favrat d'aider des abf des
architectes des bâtiments de france
ça fait des années que ça dure
aujourd'hui on sait donc maintenant
qu'on pourra pas jouer à montbron la
saison prochaine on peut déjà pas joué
notre huitième de finale contre toulouse
chez nous sommes on veut un mont boron
ce qui gâche évidemment déjà la fête
vis-à-vis de nos supporteurs et de
l'engouement que ça avait généré les
seizièmes donc on est très déçu car
évidemment on va essayer de trouver des
solutions on travaille là dessus parce
que on a deux sites porsche manthey
n'est mont boron donc on est en train de
voir comment on peut en tirer le
meilleur
ensuite la question on nous parle
souvent de et un stade est ce que vous
allez construire un stade c'est une
hypothèse mais pour l'instant non on est
obligé de lévis d'amende- de fer avec
les structures existantes et on va
essayer
rapidement de nous mettre en conformité
avec le cahier des charges de la de la
fédé et la possibilité éventuelle de
jouer et prochaine en national et
j'imagine que vous travaillez également
en étroite collaboration avec youssef
chebbi sur le mercato est ce que c'est
un sujet qui vous passionne aussi et qui
est important pour le club qui me
passionne c'est un bien grand mot c'est
important de 2,2 de mettre l'équipe dans
les meilleures conditions c'est
important de pas avoir de regrets à la
fin de saison donc c'est possible qu'on
se renforce de deux ou trois joueurs
parce qu'on a un effectif qui est pas si
important que ça quantitativement on et
21 plus 3 gardiens c'est ça oui c'est ça
bon compte tenu des périodes sanitaires
très compliqué le coville les blessures
éventuelles les suspensions il faut
qu'on soit sans doute un petit peu mieux
armé pour finir le championnat puis
surtout pour pas avoir de regrets on est
trop bien placé aujourd'hui pour jouer
la montée ou en tous les cas être dans
la compétition pour la montée avec trois
quatre équipes probablement il faut
jouer notre coup à fond parce que c'est
une chance d'être bien placé à mi
parcours mais c'est pas gagné donc on
sait que le plus dur reste à faire
continuer à rester plus longtemps
possible en tête et et puis donc en
renforçant l'équipe on se dit que on
amènera des joueurs qui vont avoir
l'ambition de nous renforcer c'est ce
qu'on recherche évidemment et qui
doivent aussi s'intégrer dans dans un
vestiaire où il ya de la joie il ya déjà
une complicité qui s'est établie donc il
faut qu'ils s'intègrent par l'état
d'esprit par leur volonté de nous nous
rejoindre leurs qualités sur le terrain
la nation vous l'avez évoqué il y aura
ce huitième de finale contre toulouse
une équipe de ligue 2 comment vous voyez
ce match ce que ça sera le petit poucet
face aux gros ou est ce que vous vous
dites finalement c'est peut-être jouable
c'est jouable évidemment pas déclaré
forfait parce que toulouse nous fait
peur au point qu'on n'a pas envie de les
jouer non bien sûr que bien sûr que
c'est jouable mais c'est un sacré
challenge on va essayer de le relever on
va essayer de poursuivre l' aventure
parce que vous risquez un petit
pronostic
moi je verrais bien un partout et on
passe aux tirs au but merci jean luc
arribart et on vous le souhaite
youssef chebbi l'entraîneur de l'équipe
première et avait côté alors youssef
chimiques comment se déroule cette
saison 2021 2022 enfin plutôt bien
puisque on est sur une place favorable
pour l'accession en n1 jusqu'à présent
et on est qualifié pour les huitièmes de
finale de coupe de france donc pour
l'instant les les feux sont au vert
c'est à espérer ou pas cette seconde
place dans le championnat de nationale 2
pour l'instant et ces 8e de finale
contre toulouse non ce serait
présomptueux de le penser alors on
prépare toutes les rencontres pour les
remporter c'est certain maintenant
on restait malgré tout une équipe qui
avait déserté les championnats nationaux
depuis une vingtaine d'années donc on y
revenez avec beaucoup d'humilité donc ça
se passe plutôt bien avec un groupe qui
s'est renouvelé cet été donc une
cohésion qui qui prend plutôt bien
jusqu'à présent il ya un parcours d'un
parcours on performe pour l'instant on
prend les matches les uns après les
autres donc ça se passe bien vous êtes
au club depuis de nombreuses années vous
avez vu les nouveaux investisseurs qui
sont arrivés ici au club ces derniers
mois comment vous vivez cette situation
vous
ben moi je suis spectateur et acteur je
suis un salarié du club jusqu'à présent
depuis quelques années et c'est positif
parce que c'était espéré depuis un
certain temps pour pouvoir poursuivre le
projet qui a été
impulsée depuis quelques saisons
maintenant il était nécessaire pour
pouvoir rivaliser avec les équipes de la
division mais d'apporter un souffle
nouveau que ce soit au niveau des moyens
humains et moyens financiers quel est
votre style de jeu une seule chibi vous
êtes plutôt un entraîneur défensif
offensif
bon moi je suis je suis un peu les deux
vous avez honte dans un match on a des
aspects qu'on doit gérer défensivement
et offensivement donc je ferai recherche
permanente d'un équilibre donc faire en
sorte d'être bien évidemment solide dans
l'animation défensive que tous les
joueurs sont que soient concernés pas
par le travail défensif et après
offensivement bien sûr avoir des
possibilités
des multiples possibilités pour pouvoir
mettre l'adversaire en difficulté vous
préférez quoi que votre équipe joue bien
ou remporter la victoire
vous savez on peut pas avoir une saison
linéaire manière générale on a des
périodes où on est bien
on doit s'adapter aussi aux éléments les
périodes hivernales notamment
après on sera toujours
on est toujours obnubilés par le
résultat quoi qu'il arrive et tout ce
qu'on entreprend sur le terrain est
guidé par l'envié de marquer des buts et
celle de remporter les matches et malgré
l'effort les moments où parfois on peut
être un peu moins bien dans le jeu si on
réussit à préserver résultat c'est
l'essentiel mais bien évidemment que
qu'un esprit de jeu une philosophie de
jeu des principes à respecter font que
nous dureront beaucoup plus dans dans
dans la compétition et dans la
performance donc c'est pour ça que c'est
aussi un équilibre à trouver vous avez
vu les joueurs qui vous correspond
peut-être à votre style de jeu voulait
chercher ses joueurs oui bah je perds
depuis quelques saisons j'ai cette
liberté à versailles de pouvoir
choisir les joueurs que je souhaite
c'était encore le cas cet été donc bien
sûr je sens un exercice important
essentiel dans la réussite d'une saison
même si on peut pas réussir
complètement dans les recrues et dans
les profils con qu'on souhaite mais ça
se passe plutôt bien et tous les joueurs
qui ont été choisis depuis des années et
encore plus cette saison c'est des
joueurs qui ont été observées qui on a
pris du temps avec qui on a discuté
échangé pour aussi s'assurer d'un état
d'esprit qui à mes yeux est essentielle
je suis maintenant avec deux joueurs de
versailles inzia et ludovic alors enza
pour comment se déroule cette saison
2021 2022 pour toi ici à versailles
plutôt pas mal hein on a bien commencé
l'année passée pas fini la saison n'est
qu'à la moitié il faut continuer faut
redoubler d'efforts et faire encore
mieux pour la deuxième partie parce que
tu prends du plaisir et ici à versailles
oui oui
- déjà là-bas jeunes de la région
parisienne du coup la ceinture autour
pour moi et franchement je prends du
plaisir sur le terrain et en dehors et
je pense que ça se voit
ludovic même chose pour toi tu prends
beaucoup de plaisir ici a évolué à
versailles oui franchement le plutôt
surpris en arrivant ici je n'attendais
pas mais en fait tout se passe bien le
groupe il est il est bon j'entends tous
bien donc les résultats suivent aussi
donc on est content pour l'instant pas
partie de saison impeccable de france a
encore qualifié championnat ça se passe
bien donc il faut continuer à travailler
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est une
première partie de saison quasi parfaite
qui a réalisé versailles casino voilà on
a perdu un match mais
c'est une bonne saison mais championnat
il est il est très long donc il faut pas
s'arrêter là et continuer à travailler
en fait partie comme une des meilleures
équipes du championnat on est d'accord
oui pour l'instant oui mais par
expérience ça va très vite donc il faut
vraiment continuer à bosser on peut être
en haut à la marche et de la saison et
puis finir 10e 1 d importer donc il faut
faut être sérieux et continue à
travailler comme on fait depuis le début
tout le monde en parle de ce match
contre toulouse ce match de coupe de
france il a toi comment tu le ressens
toi ce match de coupe de france à ce que
tu es déjà focalisé là-dessus où on
prend les matches les uns après les
autres et on prend les matches les uns
après les autres on sait que c'est à la
fin du mois c'est
29 ou 30 janvier du coup nous reste
encore on a des matches de championnat
avant il faut qu'on soit focus déjà sur
le championnat la coupe c'est vraiment
bonus l'a déjà arrivé déjà en 8e de
finale c'est déjà un beau parcours on
rencontre une ligue 2 du coup c'est très
bien pour nous pour le club pour nos
familles pour
l'ensemble on ensemble mais en tout cas
l'essentiel c'est le championnat la
coupe c'est vraiment du bonus comptant
ce tirage face à toulouse on aurait
préféré une ligue 1 c'est à dire paris
marseille un gros gros gros mais faut
pas négliger toulouse c'est quand même
une grosse équipe c'est quand même un
club pro et surtout ils sont pas mal en
ligue 2 ils sont il marche un peu sur
l'eau du coup avec une grosse attaque du
coup faire attention vous êtes milieu
défensif 1 il faudra arrêter tous les
ballons c'est ça oui c'est sa seule
balle au sol joueurs
mais bon
il est d'avis que la même chose ça sera
un gros match ce match contre toulouse
quand même cynique 201 fait un gros
match a porté le moment c'est un club
pro donc fait un gros match peu importe
l'équipe ligue 2 ligue 1 nous on est
content donc c'est une fête pour tout le
monde et même si la priorité reste le
championnat
on va prendre ça comme ça vient on est
là pour s'amuser c'est pour les joueurs
vous l'aurez compris le sait versailles
78 a de grandes ambitions pour la
prochaine année le prochain rendez vous
ce sera contre toulouse ce huitième de
finale de coupe de france